قصف واشتباكات عنيفه في الخرطوم رغم
الهدنه
اردوغان يظهر بوجه شاحب وعينين منتفختين
بعد الوعكه واخره نيره تطالب عائله القاتل
بعشره ملايين جنيه
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه اهلا بكم
نبدا نشرتنا من السودان الذي دخل فيه
الصراع يومه 13 ورغم الهدنه المعلنه الا
ان الاشتباكات تجددت في اكثر من نقطه بين
الجيش والدعم السريع حيث افاد مراسل
العربيه باندلاع اشتباكات عنيفه باحياء
جنوب الخرطوم كما اضاف بوقوع قصف لطائرات
تابعه للجيش لمواقع الدعم السريع بمحيط
القياده العامه والقصر الرئاسي بالعاصمه
مشيرا الى ان القوات المسلحه دفعت
بتعزيزات باتجاه جسر شامبات في مدينه
الخرطوم بحري وياتي ذلك بينما تستمر وحركه
النزوح من العاصمه وعمليات الاجلاء عبر
ميناء بورتسودان
ونبقى في السودان وبعد ساعات من تحذيرات
امميه من خطر بيولوجي بعد السيطره على
مختبر حساس في الخرطوم اوضحت مصادر
للعربيه ان مسلحين يرتدون زي الدعم السريع
اقتحموا المختبر المركزي المعروف باسم
معمل ستارت المصادر ذكرت ان المختبر يضم
عينات فيروسيه لامراض بالغه الخطوره
وسريعه العد مثل الحصبه والسل الرئوي
والشلل والكوليرا بالاضافه لعينات محوره
من كورونا فيما حذرت الصحه العالميه من ان
اي تعامل غير سليم مع تلك العينات قد يؤدي
الى كارثه
بعد انسحابه من لقاء تلفزيونيا على الهواء
مباشره قبل يومين لاصابته بوعكه صحيه
ظهر الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان عبر
رابط فيديو مع نظره الروسي فلاديمير بوتر
اللافت في الامر ان اردوغان بدا شاحبا
وعيناه منتفختان وقد جلس خلف مكتبه اثاء
مراسم عبر الانترنت لتدشين محطه للطاقه
النوويه قامت روسيا ببنائها فيما نفهم
مسؤولون اتراك اشاعات تم تداولها على
الانترنت تازعم ان اردوغان يعاني من مرض
خطير وجرى نقله الى المستشفى
الى مصر هذه المره حيث لا تزال تداعيات
قضيه مقتل الطالبه الجامعيه نيره اشرف على
يد زميل لها مستمره حتى اليوم اذ قررت
محكمه ادقهليه تحديد يوم الاحد المقبل
للنظر في الدعوه المقدمه من محامي الفتاه
ضد القاتل محمد عادل والتي يطالب فيها
بتعويض مالي لاسرتها قدره 10 ملايين جنيه
واكد محامي اسره نيره للعربيه ان انه اعلم
الجاني بتلك الدعوه مضيفا ان والده القاتل
هي الوريثه الشرعي له ولذلك يتوجب عليها
سداد التعويض عند اقراره من قبل القضاء
وفي خبرنا الاخير تتفاعلوا قضيه طلاق
اللاعب المغربي اشرف حكيمي من زوجته عارضه
الازياء الاسبانيه من اصول التروسيه هبه
عبوك بشكل واسع على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي حيث انتقد الممثله الايطالي
اليساندرو ليكيو طليقه اشرف حكيمي بسبب
مطالبتها الماديه الكبيره بعد انفصالها عن
لاعب باريس سان جيرمان والمنتخب المغربي
واضاف ليكيو ان طلب عشره ملايين يورو هو
امر يجعل من الزواج عملا تجاريا واصفا
الطلب بغير الصائب من سيده اعمال ناجحه
ومثقله بالديون مثل هبه عبوك على حد وصفه